so yeah this one's a little more
specialized in that the people i was
having coffee with this morning were all
physicists and this is really an
astronomer symbol not a physicist symbol
and in fact it's a symbol that so little
used in the rest of physics that
actually when i asked them what an
epsilon would look like none of them
could tell me
rather less well-known signal so i've
got to pull one from the greek alphabet
this time this is the greek letter
epsilon uh looks really rather like a
seagull it's kind of usually drawn
something like that and depending on
which font you're using it may have a
little bar at the bottom so that's the
greek letter epsilon and it's used by
astronomers in particular
to measure a quantity called the mass to
light ratio
which is really just the ratio between
the mass of an object and the amount of
light it gives out
it's usually measured in solar units so
in these units the sun comes out as one
because it's one solar mass divided by
one solar luminosity which gives you one
but the beauty of it is if you took a
thousand stars like the sun and stuck
them all stuck them all together
and then then you figured out the master
like ratio of that you'd have a thousand
times the mass of the sun divided by a
thousand times the luminosity of the sun
which is still one because a thousand
over a thousand is one so really
measuring the mass to light ratio is
telling you what something's made of if
i take a billion stars like the sun and
stick them all together to make a galaxy
it's matched to light ratio you would
still expect to come out as one
we when we first started looking at
galaxies
i guess this kind of work was first done
in the 1970s in the mid to late 1970s
people first started measuring these
quantities for galaxies and they were
expecting the answers to come out about
one because you know the galaxy's made
up of stars pretty much like the sun and
so we expected the answer to come out to
be one but when we actually went and
measured it that's not what we found we
were getting answers like 10 or 20 or 30
which tells you that there's an awful
lot more mass associated with galaxies
than just what we were expecting from
stars like the sun and this was really
some of the first really strong evidence
that the universe is full of this stuff
that we call dark matter things that
gives out
no light at all but has lots of mass
associated with it so mike hi a higher
numbers indicating some kind of diluting
force exactly it tells you there's
something else there there's something
else adding to the mass that's not
adding to the light so you add a bigger
number in the top no no bigger number in
the bottom in your fraction master light
ratio and so epsilon gets to be very big
does it ever go the other way there are
so there are some things which have a
lower master like ratio so for example
very very massive stars
mass stars that may be 10 or 20 times as
massive as the sun can easily be a
thousand or ten thousand times as bright
so very massive stars have enormous
amounts of light and although they are
more massive than the sun not that much
more massive so they can have master
light ratios at a fraction of 1.1.01 but
they're the exception rather than the
rule